the play
it's been a cool two months since
titanfall Titan fell into our living
rooms and we've all been dropping
terrible Titan puns ever since you guys
do that too right ok now the expedition
DLC offers three new maps to add to the
15 original and our first impressions
are that hey they're pretty great they
each feel fresh distinct and ripe with
opportunity for that most enjoyable of
titanfall endeavors finding new ways to
creatively clamber your way into a
position to destroy all enemy is let's
start with swampland make all the Star
Wars references you like they are
totally warranted although there are no
log traps you can use to compact a Titan
you can still scramble through these
tall trees as you traverse the area
between the modern outposts and the
ancient ruins be sure you're rocking the
enhanced parkour kit though because some
of those jumps are longer than they look
zip lines and fallen tree ramps help you
ascend to the canopy or rock it down
into the enemy base for a hard point
capture so defenders should keep a keen
eye on these points of ingress and
remember even if you're not all the way
up high using the trees for a quick wall
run speed burst can lead to some very
fast flag captures but as fun as it can
be to get arboreal as a pilot some of
the most intense tree fights are in
Titans huge trunks and low temples
provide big cover but you can both
deliver and dodge serious damage by
dancing among the trees to the extent
that a hulking 2-story death machine can
actually dance the trees may seem like
the perfect escape route for a Titan
fleeing with a flag but alas that is no
longer possible the ability to carry a
flag in a Titan has been patched out of
the game regardless of whether or not
you buy the dlc so you're gonna have to
hoof it or learn it the hard way
now let's leave all this yucky
allergenic nature behind and get real
industrial with it the runoff map is set
in some kind of sewage factory
processing plant thingy which means a
lot of right angles and a lot of
elevated pipe work for pilots to scurry
along it's a bit reminiscent of the
Demeter map but instead of roads
surrounding a dominant central structure
runoff offers narrower routes at
multiple elevations maintaining the
height advantage in a Titan often means
you'll get a better shot at your targets
weak spots once their shields go down
but don't underestimate the power of
being sneaky taking potshots from lower
levels or from behind cover can be very
effective in a map like this that has an
abundance of fairly narrow sight lines
don't forget you can duck wall in your
Titan to get a little more cover which
can make a big difference here on runoff
and pilots work those windows spending
time on the exterior of these buildings
makes you a prime target for Titans and
pilots alike even if those pilots aren't
like you know the sharpest of shooters
oh my god who took this footage you guys
oh so embarrassing could you please just
hit that pilot a chase line terrible
terrible okay finally we've got war
games a map that really only exists
inside your mind or like inside of this
VR pod that probably smells like fear
sweat and onions shoot an enemy soldier
on this map and she won't crumble into a
horrible lifeless husk she'll just
evaporate into magical Tron squares
video game violence isn't really violent
at all lawl JK totally is ostensibly
developed with chunks of other maps
wargames nonetheless feels like its own
beast with the rough realistic buildings
on either end of the map linked by
gleaming structures and neon highlights
there are some very clear wall running
corridors for pilots worth arc mining
perhaps and some very segregated
crossmap paths for Titans which are
fourth arc mining perhaps this can make
capture the flag matches very brisk
indeed while last Titan standing rounds
tend to end up on one end or the other
with everyone duking it out except that
one dude who is still on a flanking run
the long Titan runs means you can find
some pretty lengthy sight lines but the
abundant wall running space makes this
one of the more rodeo friendly maps
around smoke them if you got them the
three maps in the expedition dlco runya
999 or you can bet on the next 2 DLC
packs being good by season pass for 2499
and save five bucks there's also a
pretty hefty patch that makes a bunch of
small fixes and a few tactical ones
including the aforementioned no flags in
Titans rule it also lets you name your
custom loadouts in gives you two bonus
loadouts per match type there are more
custom match settings dome shields offer
better defense and there are some tweaks
to normal and nuclear ejection
explosions you should probably just read
the full notes online but I have
personally reached my daily quota for
reading and so now we'll go play more
titanfall after ending this video with a
sweet spin kick hi-yah Hodgins the
fallen
oh how they fall in Titans